haha the Joe Rogan experience do I don't
think movie theaters gonna be dead
because I think everyone likes the the
experience of leaving the house right
but they like blockbuster too it's great
you get to go out of the house you pick
whatever you want do a little flirty you
know that you're not really gonna watch
the movie cuz you plan on deep [ __ ]
right get this Red Vine you let them
pick some stupid movie that you never
watch some Reese Witherspoon Legally
Blonde - yeah the dogs so cute come on
let's get out of here never forget my
mom so wild I'll never forget when we
get to the front they like you you have
late fees of $275 oh my god late fees
were brewed all my mom would like can we
just listen let's just get through this
and then we'll be back next week and
we'll pay it and she would never pay it
late fees were brutal Road we just keep
the [ __ ] movie you know what else is
brutal does a little mom-and-pop little
[ __ ] ones that had the porno section
they had to kick open like the outdoor
Josey Wales yeah they had to had the
little too curtains you know the Outlaw
Josey Wales when they always kick open
those saloon doors yes that's what Joey
Diaz is famous rep with the one of those
biggest references he's always talking
about kicking open saloon doors like The
Outlaw Josey Wales but they always had
beads they always had desert Suns do you
remember those I've met curtains you're
you're a lot younger than me how old do
you now 37 yeah but there was a video
Stuart and I'll never forget this Dolby
you were you looking at the porn section
of the I would sneak in around 10:00 or
11:00 just a peek back there because
they were velvet like cleft velvet
maroon curry that's to open those beads
and people would hear the crack of your
pervertedness you
I'm gonna check saying after those beads
are saying they were sending out a Morse
code Shh I'm jerking off and you're all
like pass each other like no one would
be friendly no one to make eye contact
and a hammer so weird just picking up
boxes looking at Mike you're like you
look like you're reading the plot on the
bags it was so stupid man it was so
stupid but also fantastic none of that
now it's a it was a weird time where
like everybody knew that everybody else
watched porn - so we're oh yeah yeah
yeah I know Mike what's up and then you
know maybe that was like if you have
good friends good friends would tell
each other they beat off there's a lot
of guys out there lying to each other oh
I don't even like porn magazine after
magazine throat jacking off in the
forest - magazine I used to have a bit
that I I never wanted uh putting this on
a special like I wrote it and I
performed it then it like my special was
too long I think it was triggered or one
of the other ones but it had a whole bit
about when I was a kid we would find
porn in the forest colors some dudes who
were so scared you're so scared of the
fact they beat off they have to hide
their [ __ ] in the wood oh my god if they
go to the world you should release that
bit like a body just redo it I just read
and release it yeah because I think it
the problem the problem is sometimes I
get on a subject and I do too much on
that subject I might have had too many
jerking off jokes holiness nothing off
joke yeah [ __ ] but you have to if
you're doing a whole special and you
have 20 tighten up your ship but that's
a thing like that back then
you know it was it never existed before
so when I was a kid when I was in high
school that's when the VHS tape became
common in households in my neighborhood
at least I don't remember what the year
was they invented the VHS type VHS tape
but I remember the first time I ever saw
TV on a thing
that you could push into the television
and watch it and play it and then people
figured out that this is a good way to
watch people [ __ ] I was a senior in high
school he went from freshman in high
school nobody watched people [ __ ] to
senior high school my friends were like
she's stealing tapes from their dad's
and buying them off other dudes was
phases of death big when you were yes
that was hot that was just after high
school yes just after high school you
had phases of death and then there was
also [ __ ] like barnyard Betty where
there was this this poor fetal alcohol
syndrome baby that grew up to be a
[ __ ] up lady who was on drugs is
having sex with all these different
barnyard animals oh my god and so I I
was at my friend Billy's house and we
went down to his basement watching TV
and our other friend Ron is guarding the
door he's making sure that it opens up
the door for parents so he's gonna he's
like look out at the door while we're
watching this chick suck off a German
Shepherd oh my god this is crazy because
you know we were like 20 or something
like that
and we couldn't believe that the to any
20 year old kid if you said you know
that there's ladies that if you pay him
enough - suck off dogs they're like what
they'll feel like ah but they'd be like
duh yeah yeah here's a whole reddit
[ __ ] sub thread I know now ready a
subreddit dedicated entirely to chicks
who blow dogs some VCR was released in
1977 in the United States faces of death
came out the next year and then in 1985
on a mathematics teacher showed it to
his class in escondido high school he
fired two of the students were so
traumatized natural fear of dying and
suffering emotional distress yeah yeah I
couldn't watch that one it was in high
school the other thing is how much of it
was real though it's a good question I'd
have to see it now and so it was the
most should what you I'm sure what you
to say the the VHS was invented 76177 so
I was uh in I was in ninth grade in
nineteen
one that was my first year as a high
school student so that was like right
when that was kind of kicking in when
you know when it was getting you know
when a new invention like a thing that
you can play tape and you can watch
movies in your house that should take
took a year or two back - oh yeah just
spread across Betamax was the year and a
half fish for it cuz VCR took off in
Japan and says this says Betamax came
out in 1975 ya weren't the first mean is
VHS yeah VHS was inferior to Betamax but
Betamax was a Sony product and it was it
was only Sony so was you had to only use
their stuff right and apparently was way
better and smaller they [ __ ] up with
mini disc you know there fuk they've had
that problem a few times your Sony ATAR
one a few times discman and like zr2 was
the first one it was pop open on top
yeah you went put it straight in it pop
up top and then he put in bro I remember
we go to the gym and dudes would have a
disc hand on their hip yes a big yellow
plastic thing where the CD would sit in
and they'd be at the gym lift in like
how cool that guy looks like he's got
his own music hell yeah they called the
skip protection ESP because it looked at
that and wouldn't forget and that was a
big deal could we skip the wouldn't skip
it you could shake it when skip I
remember when they first figured out how
to do that in cars I was like God they
nailed it because before if you were
driving in your car and you hit a bump
your [ __ ] music would ruin we didn't
[ __ ] the song nightmare it was basically
your driving around at a record player
but they did have a record player for a
car even before that they had record
players for cars and like the 50s well
the record like a 78 really I know yeah
yeah see if you can find that we've
talked about this before record players
in cars it was really old I want to say
they didn't know what to do there was
some for being quarantined just fishing
we're quarantined yeah that's what
they're doing what kind of life was that
living in the 20s romero all the CDs you
have there all this night that you'd
have asked up the black case and be full
remember those things you have those
towers
[Applause]